thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a fatherly
wild ride with Stevo my dad is just a
star there's no other way to slice it
the first episode we did with him way
back was just so heartwarming and
wonderful and this time around a lot has
changed dad is just kind of bashing me a
lot but he's also now on my payroll
I mean it's crazy the way the the life
works man and uh boy is this full circle
and I think really inspiring man plus I
almost cry on this one so uh it's a big
deal let's get into it
where do I position this so I'm just
away from your mouth
okay and that looks good that looks good
yeah that looks really good you look
really comfortable that to your camera
this is oh that's my camera so over okay
yeah we used green for you last time I'm
not mad at the idea of sticking with
green I don't see anything do you
remember that there you go there you go
how do you remember that I remember I I
remember with the other RV a sense of
hypocrisy because Steve was such a
animal lover and it bothered him when he
couldn't get a car he got a car but it
was leatherette seats and people would
think that it was real leather and that
offended his sense and this is just fake
fur right but but but to me it's it's
disrespectful of the animals
I was offended by the seats being
leather and I cut out the leather yeah I
know you did but then it bothered you
that people thought that you had the
leather because the fake leather was so
realistic this is so obviously fake
leather ladies and gentlemen
this is great right here Dad episode
part two the second appearance now we're
on the tour bus what do you think of the
tour bus uh it's
interesting you call it I called Gigi uh
and I called it that I think before
you'd even close the purchase correct uh
Gigi standing not for a sexy woman but
for gas guzzler yeah I think you kind of
discovered that and it's worth it to you
I'm not suggesting that you either can't
or shouldn't afford it but it's just a
feature that is important to anybody who
might consider getting one of these
things well the Dynamics of my tour
being a theater tour with each night
representing a different city really
precludes airplane travel so we're
either going to rent a bus or buy a bus
I agree with that and and you've done
well in the theaters and the theater is
generally I guess are easier for finding
parking uh that's true too and plus I
don't have to worry about it because
we've got a bus driver well that's a
plus as well yeah so so you're on the
bus it's it's comfy it's got a lot of
recording [__] all over the place and
you know crap food and and uh but it's
nice yeah yeah it's nice it's nice and
um when you refer to my closing the deal
on the the RV tour bus you know all
about that because you're so intimately
looped into my uh my business and uh
the the the Affairs of my business
absolutely and it was to me I guess it
was a chicken and an egg you couldn't do
the theater tour without the bus but if
the theater tour didn't work you were
taking on a lot of overhead that might
be difficult to justify and you brought
it together you know the timing was not
only good but you managed it and it's
turned out to be highly successful I I
am not being critical of you having the
tour bus but it does I I'm just haunted
by the animals that are represented
all right
um now since the last time that you were
on the hit wild ride with Stevo podcast
you've
become a formal member of my team not
just a supportive dad but it started
with uh the the the
restructuring of my business management
he helped with that and you came on my
team in a formal paid capacity right
then it expanded to you being in charge
of my insurance needs yes because
insurance is is an Achilles heel for me
right and then it expanded even further
to uh to to I would say a human resource
capacity
and don't forget the legal the legal
right so
so it's it's pretty crazy to me
like just to imagine if
if
20 years ago 30 years ago if you if you
said to a young Steve-O
hey you know what it's actually gonna
work out for you you're actually going
to achieve
um and an international level of uh
exposure and and and and you're gonna
have a successful career and your dad is
going to be on your payroll
like that would that'd be too much and
here we are and that's what it's great I
guess the thing that's surprising to me
is that
um
not all but
virtually all of
my business experience came with large
corporations
and it's fascinating to me how the
disciplines the learning experiences and
the practices can translate
across different businesses you're a
relatively small business
by corporate standards very small but
within the entertainment business even
relatively small uh you're notably
undisciplined much of the time
um and and yet it works because
translating the principles that large
companies follow into
simplified programs that can be
effectively implemented in smaller
companies
is really incredible and I had one
experience I was doing some independent
Consulting for a golf course Golf Course
developer in Vero Beach and the
assignment was you know bringing to his
development
managers you know large company
structures and disciplines like job
descriptions like financial reporting
like strategies like all this kind of
stuff that we're now talking about and
it literally does translate yeah and
when you say I'm undisciplined much of
the time I think I'm actually really
quite consistent in being very
disciplined
in distinct areas and very undisciplined
in other areas all the time there's a
fight there's a fine line between
self-discipline and compulsiveness
okay I I compulsiveness you are
fantastic when you're interested in
something right but frequently uh far
more important things that you're not
interested in kind of Fall by the boards
right and that's been a problem we might
as well come you know be candid and and
talk about what I describe as an
intervention which you and Scott
Randolph over here how many
interventions have we had I mean there
was one that really stuck out when I
came out to California in this past
couple of months I thought that was kind
of a big one that was an intervention
for uh the big picture of my business
sort of you know world where are you
talking about I'm talking about the
phone call where Dad said hey you know
it's really demoralizing to work
extremely hard on putting something
together for you and then presented all
of our work to you in an email which
doesn't even get opened
and uh and and and that really that
really stung you know that really stung
in it and um and it's tough I really do
and I think that as undisciplined as I
am when I'm not
you know on fire for something the one
Saving Grace is that I've managed to
surround myself with a team of people
who fill in my gaps you have
and I honestly I'm proud to be a part of
that I love it I love I I'm so proud of
having you on my team I'm so grateful
for having you on my team and you you
genuinely
help my team so much but they're you
know there is a hidden agenda that I
feel very strongly about and I've told
you this before but for the benefit of
the uh you know the camera
um
there are a small minority of
entrepreneurs become successful
but in absolute numbers there are a lot
of successful very wealthy people
and the small businesses grow and
typically a business reaches a certain
size where it becomes too big for the
entrepreneur
to be able to manage it within his
Comfort System uh
one exit strategy is to sell out to a
larger business and take a bunch of
millions of dollars
the other is to be a compulsive control
freak and insist on running it yourself
until you run into the ground and you
don't have any millions of dollars uh in
your case you don't have the option to
sell because your business is your brand
you are the business and so it's
important to me to get you to a point
where you can manage you can fulfill the
role of a professional manager I'm not
going to be around forever I'm almost 80
years old
there's a Race Against Time to Get You
competent before I'm no longer in the
picture
man is that tough to swallow to swallow
that's tough to hear
um
and uh I think it makes for a good time
to mention how universally as I
understand it universally well received
the first podcast that you and I
recorded together how moving and and and
just beautiful it was you know to to be
able to express my gratitude for our
relationship but I didn't get as many
hits as Tony Hawk that week no I don't
know I don't know I'm not sure
every ranks among the more popular ones
you're you're a top tier guest fantastic
right and um and and I don't think that
we need to drag everybody through the
minutia of my my business world but
um strides are being made for me to
become more competent of a manager and
the boys are a long way to go but
they've come a long way too yeah the
glass is half full is not half empty
right well well part of the part of the
argument for me is like
how many days in a row have you
meditated
I have meditated for uh
1100 and some days in a row 20 minutes
in the morning 20 minutes at night
typically I do 25 minutes in the morning
and 16 minutes at night your life your
life would change your business life
would change significantly if you just
looked at your emails five minutes a
morning
that would probably solve every problem
that you ever have
you think he could solve a problem with
that magnitude in just five minutes I I
mean
how many how many emails are do you
think you're behind now
because the last intervention he was
like five or six hundred and then he
swore you'd never do it again I swear I
would never do it again I swore that I
would get better at it and I did get
better at it and recognizing that the
problem is not going to be entirely
fixed I think that what we have
adapted to is a system by which we alert
me to really important stuff that needs
immediated attention recognizing that
I'm never going to be on top of all of
the emails and when we do alert me to
something important that needs immediate
attention my track record is pretty good
for giving that immediate attention 88 I
would say all right well that's better
than it was before the intervention
that's what you call recovery you're on
track I'm I'm trying to figure out uh
if you're aware that something is
important
obviously you're going to give it
attention you rely
very heavily I think in Scott and Isaac
to identify for you what you should be
paying attention to and it may be a
while before they get you to answer the
phone or talk to them about it there's a
time lag there that I think still is a
problem and and it is becoming a a
smaller problem
progress man we're making big progress
right we're we're on the right track and
so my bosses said progress is important
up to a point but if that's all you got
you're going to get your ass fired what
was the thing about the newspaper I
remember you told me something about
there's like five Executives in there
and you would leave four newspapers oh
yeah yeah yeah this this uh we had uh I
guess there was a team I had five guys
that reported to me and the office was
in a big old house we got a lease on it
and uh subdivided the larger rooms into
cubicles there were probably UH 60
people more or less that occupied it and
we had complementary uh uh copies of the
local newspaper
but I forget whether it was by accident
or event certainly eventually it was but
by Design there was one fewer newspaper
than the number of people who were
entitled to pick it up on the way into
the office it reached a point where kind
of guys were walking around with the
newspaper under their arm and whoever
didn't have it
kind of felt sensitive and it was a a
hidden motivation yeah
that's why that's wild wow so so if you
didn't have the newspaper under your arm
you were a flaky late loser uh that's a
bit of an exaggeration uh there was a uh
an hour or two of sensitivity and
embarrassment uh but there there are a
lot of very good competent people that
can't get their ass out of bed in the
morning and you're one of them yeah
Scott is very very uh prejudiced against
anybody who doesn't show up exactly on
time and what dad just said is that
there are certain people who even if
they might show up a few minutes late
are uh you know valuable enough that you
gotta overlooked that but and more in
the larger corporations than even in
entrepreneurial things the uh it's like
your credibility is like Savings in a
bank right and if you spend your money
stupidly you're gonna have less savings
and not as as much to show for right if
you waste your credibility on trivial
things you're a net it's a net loss no
matter how you define it right when we
started working together you you were up
by nine and your bed was made every day
except on the road when we were doing
late shows but
that that was your thing yeah that is
that was something that um continued
after uh my uh living in a halfway house
where that was the rule yeah and um
I I don't want to say that that
institutionalized I mean I don't know I
I uh if I sleep to a certain point then
I start feeling like okay now I'm
starting to feel like a loser but then
that doesn't happen at 9am anymore
well I feel like it's crazy
generally I'm getting up uh 10 is my my
Norm these days when you start when you
started to become a little bit
successful in the tour
and you had the merch sales developing
you frequently had to stay up until one
or two in the morning to handle the
merch after the second show right and my
sense is that's when it kind of fell off
a cliff because it gave you a legitimate
excuse to uh sleep in in the morning I
mean when I'm on tour then forget about
the morning you know what gets me out of
bed every time is a UFC Pay-Per-View
event and this weekend UFC 284 going
down in Perth Australia we got
mochachevan volkanovsky possible double
champ status on the line two titled
fights it's so much fun I love the UFC
and it couldn't be a more fun time to
bet on the UFC and if you're planning to
anyway then DraftKings sports book is
the way to go because if you go and
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
and use the promo code Stevo a mere bet
of five dollars on a UFC 284 will
instantly get you 200 in bonus bets I
don't know how they're giving away a
deal like that but I'll tell you who
they're giving it to the listeners of
the Wild Ride podcasts so if you're
thinking about gambling on UFC 284 man
did I just give you the way to do it
download
DraftKings Sportsbook app and use the
promo code Stevo five dollar bet gets
you two hundred dollars in bonus bets of
course minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details and let's get back to it
and I think we might have covered this
when we spoke to you on the podcast last
time that by going into business that
you are kind of a black sheep in your
family I wouldn't put it that way I mean
I my family are you know all academics
uh academics theologians zoologists my
grandfather wrote a number of
theological books that were acclaimed at
the time
and and that's impressive uh is there
anybody on your side of the family who
isn't at least a PhD or the equivalent I
I guess you know my my cousin on my
mother's side of the family is very much
like me you know an undergraduate degree
in a business background
yeah a similar range of interests Clyde
way and that's your cousin on the
mother's side of the family who broke my
jaw
when when I was 10 years old maybe 11
years old and and and I was going to the
baseball camp every every summer I was a
fanatic about baseball and and we were
at Clyde White's house and and uh Clyde
White's pitching the baseball to me and
I'm just roping it all over and Dad's
the the Fielding it Dad gets sick and
tired of running around after this ball
to get it back to Clyde to pitch it to
me again so he says Clyde burn it in
Faster he wants to make it more
difficult for me to hit the ball
everywhere and applied it very much
looks up to Dad Burns it in Faster Burns
it in so fast it hits me right in the
jaw and and and breaks my jaw and and so
we know that there's a problem here but
I but dad's putting me on an airplane to
fly by myself from Boston to London
England and before dad being ever the
responsible dad he says before I put you
on this flight by yourself you're gonna
eat a hamburger
he made me to Hamburger
shut up and eat it I though I I think I
offered it and you politely uh declined
and you suffered the pangs of hunger in
the long flight to London I think he
made me eat it
bro that's fun it's fun and it's funny
and uh yeah you're you're right that
your cousin is uh very much a successful
businessman correct
um and and and the other thing that's
kind of interesting
um you had a one of the distinctive
features of your childhood was that when
we moved back to London you were age 10.
nine not nine about
is it nine nineteen and turned 10 in
fourth grade okay okay fair enough uh
almost not almost 10. and I remember
getting a phone call from the mother of
one of your classmates uh they were
inviting you to go and do a an overnight
with them one weekend and she called up
to find out if we minded you traveling
on the London Underground
and their son who was also about 10 and
they'd lived there for a while was
StreetWise and and allowed to travel in
the underground so I talked to your mom
and said well if that's the way it works
you know he's getting a early start but
that's going to be good and in no time
at all you were traveling independently
all over London using the underground
system to go wherever the hell you
wanted to go at the age of 10. yeah and
there are a lot of people I guess that
might call that irresponsible parenting
but the flip side of that argument is
that every kid
inevitably comes to a point of
vulnerability of risk and kids that have
grown up in American suburbs and never
been able to go anywhere unless driven
by their parents and then the big thing
is to get their driver's license but
it's just a very very different world
right and then they get out you know you
know in the college or work or whatever
it is and you know they got drugs all
over the place and all kinds of [__]
going on and they get hit all at once a
tsunami weight of Temptations and risk
and I like to think that by spreading
that risk over your life
it was incremental and you got you you
gained you know experience you became
street smart and I think that was kind
of a maybe a risky investment but one
that paid off sure I had all the freedom
at the age of 10 that the average
American kid doesn't enjoy until they
turned 16 and and have access to a car
no you're not even close you know the
average American doesn't get close to
your freedom until at age 10 until
they're away at college and removed from
parental supervision and any kind of
Courage control and despite that being
introduced to his independence at such a
young age man did I do a tsunami of
drugs and alcohol
as soon as I got to college
hey you know all's well that ends well
right I I agree
um
and yeah you you had that disposition I
mean it didn't matter whether you were
riding the London two but 10 or whether
you were a freshman in college at 18.
you know the drugs and booze and
everything was going to come your way no
matter what for sure for sure no no
question about that
um now I wonder
um you know I I told you that I think
it's really interesting how you come
from this this uh this line of academics
with with the emphasis on Theology and
and uh clergyman I mean what's the the
the clergy influence in your family tree
clergy being somebody who's a priest or
uh some uh a church official uh maybe a
great uncle in England that I hardly
knew my grandfather uh wrote theological
books and occasionally was a guest
preacher but nobody in my family that
I'm aware of uh at least that I knew it
during my life
was ever a full-time preacher okay then
then uh I'm glad that we cleared that up
um you when you were like maybe 25 years
old before you met mom
uh younger uh uh when when did I
um I'm just trying yeah it's about right
and and uh what was it uh the the
um famous
televangelist you gotten oh this was
before I Met Your Mother
um a very good friend of mine that is
I'm still close to him
um Peter Nichols we went to nursery
school together
he he was taking his uh he was a
Univision University of British Columbia
I think he was into his master's program
then but I'm I'm not sure and I hung out
with him and uh his girlfriend had a
girl I was introduced to
she seemed kind of interesting and um
somehow I got invited to a a Sunday
luncheon at her uncle's house
and this was a guy I could instantly
respect at the time he was in his middle
40s I guess
visibly successful both in his business
and in his lifestyle and
the first indication I ever had that it
was possible both to be
relatively wealthy and successful in
business and also to be a Christian I
mean now you know there are many
examples but in those days I thought if
you're going to be a Christian you had
to be poor
and I didn't want to be poor so anyway
this guy you know Jack Oliver was an
influence and yeah his his uh niece
included me in that Sunday luncheon and
by coincidence the following week the
Billy Graham crusade was coming to
Vancouver and this was the main topic of
conversation the family were all totally
involved in the organization and the
Committees and that kind of thing and I
was living in this
boarding houses I mean it was probably
better than what you'd think of a
boarding house being today but I had a
modest room in a modest house and there
were several other guys that were paying
weekly rents to live there
and I was kind of curious about you know
this whole Billy Graham thing and my
roommate who was from Chilliwack British
Columbia and you know not too worldly a
guy but a nice guy I said hey why don't
we go to the Billy Grahams who say and
find out what it's all about and so we
went and the music and the Fantastic
shows you got sucked into it and I I I I
was I mean people say that I'm not
emotional and but I kind of got a little
bit emotional okay and so we went
forward and what I suddenly realized was
that standing behind me was
my host the uncle of and this lady could
never be called a girlfriend because
they belong to the Plymouth Brethren
sect and any uh lecturer in my mind was
a pipe dream I mean this was uh it took
me not very long to figure that out but
by then I was kind of you know okay and
I like the Sunday lunches but uh yeah he
was standing behind me and and the way
these things work you know members of
the local christian community volunteer
to uh you know sort of be a sponsor
similar to Ed so watch so what we're
gonna get into is that for uh a somewhat
brief or how long were you into the
Christian thing well I I had rejected it
in high school because I was forced to
go to church and I just looked around
and saw a bunch of Hypocrites so I'd
rejected it but this was kind of a new
thing and I got into it I had about
two and a half months three months left
uh in Vancouver and I went to the
Plymouth Brethren assembly every Sunday
and you know I went to Bible study and
all this kind of stuff and I went back
to Toronto and uh
you know I Met Your Mother and you know
she had an Anglican upbringing but she
wasn't too terribly devout and it kind
of gradually recedes so this was a
pretty brief stint yeah I bet it was an
extreme case uh for a while I lived in a
a run-down shitty big house uh where we
had about six or eight of us that paid
the rent and every weekend there'd be
guys sleeping in the floor that had
stopped in for the football game or
something and I remember one Sunday
morning this buddy of mine was
absolutely passed out from the night
before and he's asleep in the living
room floor and I said hey rich rich do
you want to come to church with me
that that didn't go anywhere but I I
decided in within six months that that
was not the life I wanted for the rest
of my life but having had that
experience I I had the monkey on my back
I had this fear of Eternal damnation and
all the stuff that the uh you know the
Evangelist evangelists uh put out and I
then my business side kicked in I said
you know if this world is finite and by
doing what I want to do I'm screwing
myself for eternity that doesn't sound
like a good strategy
so then I said I've got a
you know figure out you know a factual
basis so I don't feel vulnerable for uh
giving up on it and that started
probably uh
35 or 40 years not of intensive study
but reading a lot of different books on
various aspects of Christianity to find
what I thought were enough loopholes
that I didn't have to worry about Helen
damnation
I love that you just can't argue with my
dad's approach if you're worried about
something educate yourself with the
facts that is why I wear a whoop strap I
don't want to worry about my health so I
make sure I know the facts about my
health starting with how much I'm
sleeping how much time I'm spending in
each stage of sleep how much recovery am
I getting for the activity I had the day
before what activities am I doing how
many calories am I burning I'm telling
you this root band is so sophisticated
it now tells me how oxygenated my blood
is I mean dude skin temperature
respiratory levels I mean there are more
insights into your health than you can
get from any other Fitness device period
you want to know what's going on with
your body then wear whoop like me and
all kinds of people who know what's
going down and if you go to whoop.com
and use the promo code Stevo you get 15
off at checkout plus that's with whoop
4.0 which is the new one that has the
waterproof charger you never have to
take the band off man you just slide on
your waterproof charger boom you're good
to go
15 off at checkout is a pretty killer
deal too because the membership like
boom just got a lot more affordable and
the whoop band itself is free with the
membership so what are you waiting for
go to whoop.com and use the promo code
Stevo and get the facts about your
health
now let's get back to it
and in doing that you developed a
relationship with a pastor at the local
church in England yes and he
guided you through
uh the the
literal uh Original Scriptures that
became the Bible and the actual uh
translation from Aramaic and Greek yes
uh guided is a big word he claimed that
he could read classical Greek and I had
no uh foundation for either believing or
disbelieving that but the thing that
always bothered me among the things that
bothered me the most this uh I think
it's either Chapter 14 verse 6 in the
Book of John or 6 14 I forget the
sequence but the saying there is no way
to my father except through me right and
you see these people holding signs of
football games and TV that quote John 3
14 3 yeah whatever it is and uh
I said Gary help me with that I mean how
is it possible that a genuinely good
religion
could condemn genuinely good people to
damnation simply because they believe in
a different religion right and and to
put into perspective here what you had
done in isolating this one translated
line which says
from the Bible at the English
translation is the only way to my father
is through me yes and that and it's that
one line and only that one line upon
which this whole idea that that you have
to accept Jesus Christ as your savior to
go to heaven is based uh I'm sure
there's a lot more to it than that
that's the flagship line that's the
flagship that's the flagship line and
Gary said to me well think about this
for a second what if I gave you an
alternative translation from the
original manuscripts which was an
equally valid translation
and that translation uh would be you
know Christ speaking now that I have
come to this earth and shared my
teachings it will be easier for more
people to find God
and the light flashed on us I said son
of a [__] I mean is that really an
equally valid translation and he said
yes and then you've got to look at the
history of the New Testament there's
been
more than a hundred different English
translations you know from the original
manuscripts and in many different
languages it was first put together
at the nicenean
council in 325 under con uh Constantine
emperor Constantine and uh you know they
collected all of the senior members of
the then I guess it was a Catholic
church but it wasn't referred to as
Catholics to pull together
what the New Testament would be and they
all went through you know there are many
many manuscripts and books and competing
entries and obviously they all had an
extra grind you know they wanted the
power they wanted Consolidated and so
they chose selectively what books would
be included and what would be include
excluded and then over time uh as each
subsequent translation or addition was
produced you know the people that had
the self-interest the acts to grind were
coming up with the translations that
would best serve their purpose
and so
the other piece that came together that
was one piece that was important the
other thing I got interested in
flavius Josephus was a famous historian
at that time in in early Palestine at
the time of Christ and he uh you know
led a uh an uprising against Rome he was
captured he went back he was taken back
to Rome he befriended the emperor and he
returned to Palestine with the mission
of trying to get the Jews to accept more
peacefully the Roman rule he became the
most famous historian of that era I
don't have the credentials to validate
that but he you look him up on uh is
this the the manuscript that he wrote
which which only mentions Christ one
time in like 500 pages no 900 Pages it's
like a small paragraph yeah and and
there was this one little section on one
page and I said okay I mean yeah okay
that's possibly extreme but if all of
this [__] was going on that is the
foundation of the modern religion and if
the Evangelical theory of History was
accurate why would Josephus have so
completely ignored it right and now is
that is that absolutely compelling
decisive uh condemnation no but it's
another source of questions that starts
you thinking about the history of the
time and uh right and and yeah that that
bothered me and then uh the Catholic
which I guess is universally Christian
but the theory of original sin
and the theory that everybody is a
sinner at Birth
and uh the only way they can stop being
a sinner and well the only way they can
be saved saved is by you know accepting
Christ and there was one author uh
Burton Mack he was a theologian at the
uh University of Washington and
he was
you know a skeptic of Christianity and
one of the things I'll never forget his
theory was that at that time the
religion of the area was Orthodox
Judaism
and Orthodox Judaism had an incredible
Litany of rules I mean from not eating
shellfish you got to do this I mean it
was unbelievable
and the simple Christian doctrine Christ
embraced The Ten Commandments and
basically said if you live The Ten
Commandments you'll have a better life
and you'll be a better human being and
Burton Mack's theory was that
by Christ establishing the Ten
Commandments as the rule of the religion
all of this [__] in the Orthodox Judaism
of you know you can't do this you can't
do that you must do this you can't do
that all that kind of stuff went by the
board right and so and so in accepting
Christ it wasn't that that's the only
way of uh being saved but it's the way
that people could escape from this
incredible long list of rules that they
could never uh obey and since failure to
obey all of them meant you were a sinner
when you didn't have to obey them all
you were to sinner right and I think uh
in the in the the subject of translation
I think that it's actually
Commandments isn't it I think it's more
10 suggestions
uh I I never got to that point I'm not
going to go take either side of that
okay uh I mean basically the Ten
Commandments are essentially similar in
Judaism and Islam as well as
Christianity you know whether Moses
brought them down from the mountain and
the tablets I'm not qualified to say but
they're universally recognized as a key
to a better life right
hey gray if if all of the various
religions were just on the same page
take it all equally be you know that's
why the the church that that I
go to from time to time called The
self-realization Fellowship is
considered a church of all religions
their opening prayer is uh uh beloved
God you know uh
father mother you know Saints of all
religions we bow to you all
recognizing every religion as an equally
viable past to heaven but let me for a
second take the flip side of that you
know I can't prove this statistically
but I have a bias
that if you had
demographically matched samples of
sincere Christians in one room and
atheists or agnostics in the other room
and there was some way of measuring
their happiness in life
I would be willing to bet that the
Christian group would be more happy than
the non-Christian I don't disagree with
that and and and yet you know if you get
into the situation that I was in uh
where I felt trapped by the extremists
uh you know in the Christian faction and
had the motivation to do the reading
that I did now I came up with a uh uh
I guess understanding a limited and not
a theological or a really academic
understanding but a practical
understanding a spiritual position a
position on spirituality and the other
thing I remember talking to uh uh a
devout Christian at the golf club one
day and and I forget how it came up it
was maybe the uh we're talking about
anti-Semitism it was maybe one of the
Jewish holidays and um you know he uh
said that
anti-Semitism was either founded based
influenced by the belief that the Jews
killed Christ
I turned him and said Ron that's
[__]
Christ chose to die
he could have avoided the crucifixion
but he chose to die because it was
important to fulfill the prophecies in
the scriptures and that's why you know
on yeah he he
wasn't Christ also a Jew so to say that
the Jews killed it might be a little bit
weird well no but the the the the the
the the Jewish
establishment wanted to get rid of him
because he was undermining their control
of their population his teaching went
directly against the teaching of
Orthodox Judaism right with all the
rules with all the rules and the power
again religion a lot of
distinguish between honest religion and
organized religion organized religion is
a lot about power and there's not a
whole lot difference between the Jews
the Christians and the Muslims you know
you know the hierarchy wants to gain
build and keep power right well I also
read that like in the 14 or 1500s
Revelations wasn't even in the Bible at
the time and so that they had two
versions of Revelations one was a
positive version one was a negative
version like damnation and hell because
the church was hurting and they needed
to get people in there to donate 10 of
the like they're tithing and so they
decided to put the the negative version
in there and that's where like you know
the the horsemen of the apocalypse and
if you don't uh you know yeah whatever G
so so they chose that version to get
people scared to go to church in order
to make more money I'm not aware of that
specific but honestly but but the the
logic ties in with a lot of other logic
yeah right I I listened to a lot of uh
Bart Airman he's a Biblical scholar of
the New Testament and he debates people
all the time on that and he was a
Christian same thing but he uh he talks
about you know the fact that Matthew
Mark Luke or John they don't even they
can't even confirm that it was written
by Matthew Mark Luke or John because the
person that was writing it never even
said his own name and so they said what
a lot of people did in that time is they
would um it was like a battle to get
like not published but you know the your
Papyrus to
to circulate throughout the community
and what they think is that you know the
first
I forget which book was first but it was
written like 90 years after Christ lived
so it was like even recalling these
events or what he said it'd be like
trying to remember verbatim like
Truman's speech on TV it'd be impossible
and furthermore they said that there's
more changes
to the New Testament than there are
words I I would believe that because
because there have been so many
different interpretations and
translations
um and everyone who came up with their
own version had a personal ax to grind
right and how many how many people you
know have a deep enough knowledge of
classical Greek and Aramaic Aramaic yeah
to get into a serious debate with the
Theologian about the translations he's
chosen to put out well even in even the
word for hell was different like it
didn't mean a fiery place it just meant
like like if you if you you might be
unhappy if you do you have a burning in
your stomach like you know like anxiety
or like uh just sin the the I think the
original translation for sin was just
like missing the mark yeah but you you
go to uh you know
all the churches and art galleries in
Europe you know all the paintings show
people dying in hell and arrows in them
yeah but still that's not until like the
1500s that's true but so so I was raised
Catholic and like I saw that in my
church and I'm like sitting here
thinking like as a seven eight nine year
old kid I'm looking at uh you know Saint
felicidus perpetua getting beheaded or
like what kind of abuse is that where
you're looking at these pictures or like
they're saying like well if you know I
was always taught that like my dad was
going to hell because he wasn't a
Catholic and so it's like I'm being told
by nuns that my dad's going to hell I'm
like wait a minute like that's gnarly to
say this to some child you know have you
ever thought about what hell is
because I I you know I have a philosophy
all of these paintings in the art
galleries you know pure [__] because
they know that the body you know
disintegrates as cremated the body does
not survive so what survives is the
spirit and now you've got uh these
haunted castles in Europe these places
where supposedly the spirits roam around
and they're unhappy
my theory is that there is a spiritual
afterlife and if you have
feel guilt about sins that you committed
while you were living
you never dealt with made amends for
took care of
it's perfectly believable to me that
this in the spiritual afterlife the
spirit would be haunted by that and you
know when you say rest in peace
presumably that means you know Spirits
which are not haunted by it but the uh
Criterion there isn't what the Catholic
church or any other organized religion
says you should do it's what you feel
good or bad about yourself in terms of
the life that you lived and whether or
not you took advantage of opportunities
to make amends
Life review I I like Life review big
time and and I love that a lot
um I think that it's a a very
constructive approach that you took to
get that monkey off your back I'm glad
that you did get the monkey off your
back and I also agree that uh people
with people of Faith are happier people
I agree with that that's true and and
and and uh obviously they're not happier
people if they have faith which is going
back now a number of years deemed to be
uh
um insufficient I mean there's a awful
lot of serious persecution of people who
were genuinely religious uh that's less
of an issue now than it was but in some
countries that's still an issue right
but I I'm glad that that uh that we
discussed that and and I'm glad that you
um you wrote uh what did you call it my
uh my belief on spirituality and he
wrote it as a letter to me my sister
Cindy and uh any future uh grandchildren
alike I read it I read it in New Zealand
and I and I I didn't stop reading it
until I got to the part where you
mentioned
um that your wedding date with Steve's
mom and it was the same exact date as I
was reading it and I just was like and I
stopped and put it down it was just my
what what you mentioned the date in
there yeah it was whenever you you
married uh yeah November 10th 19th
December 18th yeah and I was literally
reading it on December 18th and I was
like oh my God this is crazy and I never
picked it back up after those words that
that would in many circles be termed
uninformed superstitions yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um but but uh it's it's it's uh a
wonderful thing that you wrote and it's
um
testimony that you're a good guy who
believes in living a good life and that
you're a very educated guy who's put a
great deal of effort into
into knowing things knowledge is power
and that's something that you've taught
me hey you know what else is power money
dude and the best way to be making money
these days is with an e-commerce
operation you build the audience online
and then you sell to the audience online
with ship station that's how I'm telling
you to buy Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole I mean there's no toilet that's
not gonna look cooler and be more fun to
sit on if it's got
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
sitting on top of it and how
sell these okay well down in my
warehouse in San Diego we use ship
station meaning that when somebody
places an order for my butt wipes uh it
prints out a label right and boom they
slapped the label on the thing and it
automatically has the lowest prices
available from all of your different
carriers like UPS the United States
Postal Service Fedex rates that are
normally reserved for Fortune 500
companies are yours with ship station
it's epic and the labels come out they
get slapped on they're out the door and
dude it all happens so quickly and so
easily plus ship station is one
interface so if you're selling from your
own website or if you're using Amazon or
Etsy it's all built into one interface
that makes it so easy to use the labels
come out they go on the package dude you
are making money and money is power so
to get a 60-day free trial with ship
station you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo and you're off to the races with
two months of hassle-free shipping the
best rates going and I mean dude what do
you got to lose everything if you're not
killing it with your own e-commerce
business you are losing everything so
get to shipstation.com use the promo
code Stevo and enjoy enjoy your power
now let's get back to it
so let's uh I I got a question okay I'm
gonna this is a good segue and I think
we talked about bringing this up so I'm
not springing it on you
um the animal sanctuary in Florida right
I I am dying to know
the case to have the animal sanctuary in
Florida is a lot better than having it
in Vancouver
of course it is Vancouver is not a place
for an animal sanctuary so where would
you want a Nana where would you advise
Steve to have an animal sanctuary
Southern British Columbia
Southern British Columbia so Vancouver I
bet like suburbs yeah go back to school
and study your geography sorry that's uh
sorry absolutely yeah yeah yeah
yes okay
um yeah we might as well get right into
this
um the
okay and in a way in a way that's
palatable for the audience I think you
could ask just about any American
um about the national debt and I think
it's common knowledge everybody's aware
that as a government as a nation America
is in insane amounts of debt and I think
that the general feeling about it for
the average American is that we're in so
much debt it's just a big joke and we're
never gonna have to pay it and la la la
la but what very few Americans I think
are aware of is that debt is a very real
thing which is going to vary in a very
real way rear its ugly head and and
create a situation
and that's the situation that makes you
very much favor Canada as a place for me
to live out my Golden Ears I was more
than that Steve I mean Canada has its
debt problems as well
um
but you're right the national debt uh
recently passed 31 trillion uh
think of that the financing cost each
percentage point of interest is over 300
billion uh the countries you know
already reeling with the debt and then
you've got the unfunded liabilities
Social Security
you've got the defense budget which
never never quits and so when you look
at the proportion of the country's total
budget
the discretionary money which could be
cut is a tiny fraction of the money
that's going out and the reason that
that survives is because the dollar is
the reserve currency of the world right
and as long as the rest of the world uh
just about every country is struggling
with its own debt problems which makes
the U.S look less bad but as long as the
dollar Remains The Reserve currency then
the you know the financing will come in
there will still be governments that buy
American treasury bonds there will still
be foreign investors that will do that
and so you know it's like a a Bernie
Madoff Ponzi scheme scheme you know it
will go on until it doesn't go on but
you know if you think about it it is
mathematically impossible
for even the existing debt ever to be
repaid because
you can't come up with any combination
of tax increases or spending cuts that
would even come remotely close so if
it's never going to be repaid and
everybody knows that when our foreign
institutions going to stop investing in
it and then what's added burden is that
going to put on the middle class who see
their mortgage rates go from six percent
to 15 percent and liquidity dry up and
everybody's so pissed off with guns all
over the place they're running around
taking the Law into their own hands
honestly that may sound Draconian it may
sound you know single-minded uh but it's
fundamentally based in fact it I believe
it's fact-based and I'd welcome an
opportunity to debate anybody who felt
that there were facts that would go the
other way and then when I looked north
of the Border I say the uh there's not
the gun culture yes there is debt but
it's because the Canadian dollar isn't a
reserve currency the Canadian debt is
more disciplined the Canadian political
system is far less fractured and
dysfunctional than the American
political system right plus the Canadian
political system doesn't allow for hands
to be tied so easily you've got the
that's right the the the the you know in
the parliamentary system uh the the
party that wins the most seats is in
power typically for four years between
UK and Canada there are minor
differences and if they've got a
majority in the parliament for four
years they can do pretty much whatever
the leader wants
recognizing that he or she knows there's
going to be election coming up so that's
the control on them to uh you know to
follow the rules and do things the right
way in this country if you've got you
know all the gerrymandering that goes on
we're uh congressional districts are
rigged by the uh party you know the
party that's running the state
government
um you know now you've got all these
lawsuits that are trying to undermine
the uh credibility the viability of the
American election system I mean where
does it all lead
and uh when you talk about Canadian real
estate being a lot more expensive than
comparable U.S real estate yes it is and
very frequently something that is more
expensive than something else is more
expensive for a reason
I you know I've said to you uh if you're
buying something for an investment you
know what you pay for is a lot lot less
important than the realistic expectation
of capital appreciation
all right and that that's a long-winded
response Scott but uh that's the
foundation of why I've been pushing
Steve to think north of the border so
Vancouver
I'm kidding but the British Columbia I
mean what what are your thoughts on
British Columbia Steve yeah stop saying
Vancouver it's like saying do you want
to have an amateur uh animal sanctuary
in the middle of Chicago of course not
why not right indoors
I've got it from here
um I agree with what dad's saying about
the benefits of Canada the less guns and
all of that
however part of my vision for the animal
sanctuary is uh
farming you know a a self-sustaining
compound where we can grow our own food
and such and just the nature of Canada
being so overcast and the weather being
so dismal I think limits how much food
we can grow there that is an unfounded
generality
not substantiated by facts well I've
done a lot of uh uh Zillow porn
Okay like you know we go through Zillow
and we call it real estate porn and all
I see that they grow there is
blueberries dad
well that's because of the uh
international trade and the centers of
excellence and the specialization but if
you go back to when uh both countries
were founded
you know the people lived off the land
and people lived off the land in the
Northern parts of the U.S just as they
did in Canada and yes it was a seasonal
farming business and they harvested in
the fall and they saved it in their
their storeroom or barn or whatever so
that they could feed themselves during
the winter and it was a form of
discipline but if you're talking about
an animal sanctuary as a business where
it has the self-sustain and run itself
how are you going to run a business when
it's closed six months out of the year
for snow overnight first of all I think
it's a pipe dream to think that that's
ever going to generate enough income to
sustain itself it's a charitable act
that may attract some visitors but
you're never going to uh you know
justify the capital investment or cover
the costs of running it on the basis of
tourist income
my thought to that is if you had an
Orlando people land not in Orlando but
between the two airports Tampa and
Orlando you know how they have little
pamphlets in the hotel rooms of like it
says do you know how many different
pamphlets are in those same hotel rooms
well why aren't you going to open it you
see a Stevo Animal Sanctuary you know I
I honestly think that's a loser Scott uh
I don't think Stevo's Animal Sanctuary
is ever going to get traction against
Universal Studios and Disney and all the
other businesses there well it's like
it's like a numbers game with foot
traffic yeah maybe maybe that doesn't
matter and you also didn't think that a
Stevo tour was gonna go anywhere you
know I was never I I shared some of your
uh uncertainties from the very beginning
but I've been a big fan believer and
supporter for at least the last 10 years
okay well what about the hot sauce
well every time I look at the P L's I I
ask myself the same question
all right well
um we've got some time to watch the real
estate prices cool off to choose between
Florida and British Columbia and the the
other thing is if if
you [__] I mean there are a lot of
Americans that within the U.S are
preparing for Doom and Gloom and they've
got their uh Cottage out in the middle
of the country and they're underground
all this kind of stuff and you know
intelligent people who are maybe opinion
leaders in that area but there is a
substantial concern already building
here yeah and uh
you know
you've not only got to think about how
many ticket sales you're going to
generalize generate for have come have
kids come and pet these poor little
animals but you've got to figure out you
know how how are you going to support
yourself how are you going to are you
going to be vulnerable uh you know if
you're in the middle of Central Florida
you're not too far from a lot of large
population centers that have a lot of
guns and a lot of angry people uh
there's a lot to think about and and and
we're we're gonna we're gonna handle
that so
um and I I'm fascinated by the the whole
take on the national debt and the future
of
America life is kind of get tough one
way or another it's just a question of
when yeah and and the other thing
politicians all over the world but
especially in this country now are
famous for kicking the can down the road
sure and so it's going to require a
Bernie Madoff kind of episode you know
to shake the system and by then a ripple
I mean it'll be even worse but what
politician is ever going to say
we're going to raise taxes by
X percent and we're going to use those
taxes to pay down the national debt
which will provide no immediate benefit
that anybody is ever going to see right
and can you imagine the commercials the
negative advertising that's going to
come up you know when they're next up
for reelection right I mean that's a
dead loser so I would just challenge I
mean if somebody says
America is the greatest and we'll muddle
through and everything's okay
it's not possible to have you know a
really intelligent conversation at this
point if you want to have a relative or
more than relatively intelligent
conversation it's incumbent on the other
side to lay out you know a road map for
how we're going to get from where we are
to where we're going to have a genuine
soft Landing uh I don't see it I won't
be around to you know suffer from it but
you will be and I think and I just think
these are important considerations right
isn't that why the fed's raising the
rate though to control the debt or try
to get it down uh they're raising the
rent the rate uh
largely because they think that's going
to reduce inflation because by raising
interest rates they're going to choke
off certain elements of discretionary
consumption and in the past that's not
had a direct effect totally but yes it
has helped you know to cool inflation
but
the other reason for raising rates is
that the national debt has to be
financed and if it's not going to go
into directly into a South American
style printing press job
treasury bonds have to be attractive to
investors and with inflation running you
know pick a number but real inflation
has got to be already north of 10
percent I read somewhere that if the
same formula that was used when Bill
Clinton was President in the early 90s
exactly the same formula we're used
today the reported Consumer Price Index
would be 12 13 14 percent
and when investors realize that that's
the effective impact of inflation and
they're getting three and three quarters
percent on 10-year treasuries
how long is that party going to go on
right so we're screwed no matter what
and there's
you know the uh the darwinian theory
survival of the fittest and the people
that are smartest are most resilient and
are best prepared you know will come out
better and there are examples of
countries that have collapsed and uh you
know re you know rediscovered themselves
post-war Germany yeah Argentina uh
Argentina maybe is a better example
because post-war Germany got enormous
support through the Marshall Plan uh
Greece go bankrupt too
there's a difference between formal
bankruptcy and Technical bankruptcy
if
and Greece got Bail Greece was a small
you know entity that the EU decided in
their great wisdom to bail them out
because if the Greeks collapsed then it
would threaten the existence of the euro
um so no that that um the Greeks are not
you know necessarily a model but you
know they're problems all over Europe I
mean I don't believe the uh Euro is
sustainable in its current form you've
got 17 countries each one of which has
its own independently democratically
elected government
that have varying degrees of
economic sophistication and success and
you've got one Central Bank that is
charged with establishing a monetary
policy that is going to work in all of
these diverse countries
all of whose governments are up for
re-election every few years right so if
you're in Germany today then you're
pulling a lot more weight than you're
picking up the slack of all these yeah I
had when the Greek crisis came
there's a this is very much in the news
media and I remember playing golf with a
guy I'd never bet met before or since he
was a German living in the UK in on in
the financial markets industry and I
asked him you know why does Germany keep
on pouring all of its taxpayer money in
the countries like Greece and he said
Portugal and Italy and Spain and he said
because if we didn't
there'd be nobody buying our Mercedes
and our BMWs so it's kind of a revolving
wheel uh recycling it but you know all
the stuff that's going on in in Russia
and the Ukraine you know is really
bringing stuff to a head there and
that's a problem
right
um you describe the problems with the EU
uh the UK after brexit like that in in
hindsight brexit was mistake can we say
that I don't agree with that uh most
people in the UK do
um I guess I put a different spin on it
when the UK was a member of the EU they
were required to contribute large
amounts of money uh to the common cause
the countries were called upon to
contribute in relationship to the
strength of their economies and it was a
political issue that a lot of taxpayer
money from the UK was going into Europe
um I struggled with brexit when it
um you know was in debate because at the
time you were living in England uh no I
I I guess I I think I I
think we just I just stopped living in
England but I was awfully close to
England I watched the UK news every day
and and all the rest of it and uh my
view then and is still my view is that
there would be a significant short-term
pain short-term meaning five six eight
years uh because of the change in the in
the trade patterns that that would be
pain to go through I said there would be
in my opinion
a long-range benefit because I honestly
believe it is a mathematical certainty
that the euro is going to collapse
because of the political conflicts and
because of the debts and without getting
into a lot of a lot of detail
that's going to be a train wreck and if
the UK was still a member of the EU
being called upon to make annual
contributions to uh you know help solve
the financial problems the EU
the potential for that to grow is
enormous so to me it was a rare case
where
short-term Prosperity was sacrificed for
a longer-term benefit all right I buy
that and I I can digest that
um you're a smart guy dad there's
there's no question about that and uh
I'm grateful for you on every level and
uh and and I love you so much and thank
you for doing this you're very very
welcome and uh
I don't love being with you and having
these conversations but I feel really
good when I kick your ass when you need
it God
or do you love my dad I mean dude now
I'm gonna share something that I
probably shouldn't but I love the street
team the people who stick around to the
very end of the podcast sometimes you
get the juicy nugs of
of info now this is what it is
um somebody reached out to us to my team
about they want to make a documentary
about Stevo now first thing I thought is
that the world's hardly hurting for yet
another documentary about Stevo but I
thought it was meaningful that they
reached out to me before finishing the
documentary and making it public like
some other people and I thought you know
what let me talk to him so I talked to
him and I was impressed by the by the
the guy I was impressed by his company
and and and I figured that a documentary
about Stevo the businessman and Stevo
and his relationship with his dad I told
this guy my dad says he's got tops 10
years of useful life left and before
that 10 years or before his life is over
he wants me to be prepared to
tear it it's just so rad so I want to
make a documentary about me and my dad
and I think I made a deal with the guy
to do it love you guys